[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro de vip aujourd'hui sur ce
plateau justice aux côtés de bernard
pinet acteur et comédien yves binois
bonjour vers l'art bonjour alors vous
habitez dans la commune de noisy le roi
vous avez joué dans de nombreux films de
nombreuses pièces et vous est notamment
connu pour votre rôle du contrôleur du
fisc lucien cheval dans la pièce le
dîner de cons on y reviendra dans
quelques instants déjà racontez nous
votre parcours
je suis en vie entre audace
rien ne me prédestinait à ce métier
le hasard la chance d'être mis en
pension et de la d'être remarqué par des
professeurs faut dire que j'étais
première citation c'est le seul endroit
dans ma vie où j'ai été premier donc ils
m'ont repéré m'ont proposé faire du
théâtre je dis pourquoi pas ça
permettait de sortir un peu de l'étude
et puis ça m'a plu et ensuite
une rencontre avec une lycéenne dont
l'oncle était un acteur professionnel on
est parti en stop à paris le voir il m'a
dit oui c'est mon petit tu peux y aller
et puis j'ai suivi les cours de pury
money le café théâtre du théâtre pour
arriver au zénith avec le dîner de cons
que j'ai joué au théâtre c'est au
théâtre de jouer avec jacques villeret
bien sûr et michel roux dans trois
tournées triomphales dans le plus grand
théâtre de france de suisse de belgique
monaco monte carl et une tournée dans
les ai dit si vous plaît dans la comédie
de donner vie au verbe de pouvoir
s'extraire de cette
carcasse charnel qui nous emprisonnent
de pouvoir défendre des des auteurs cole
porter les messages les auteurs d'auteur
de philosophes qui me semble utile pour
pour l'humanité la société des hommes
vous êtes monté à paris très jeune vous
aviez une vingtaine d'années sans un sou
en poche c'est si je peux dire est ce
que ça a été difficile au début ouais
mais comme disait rimbaud on n'est pas
sérieux quand on a 17 ans moi j'avais 20
ans donc je suis parti je n'avais rien à
perdre de toute façon puisque jeu enfin
bref c'est pas d'étude était alors que
non je me suis pas rendu compte du
danger je suis parti à cliquer ben on ne
sait pas ce serait peut-être aujourd'hui
1000 euros parce que j'avais bossé avant
à l'usiné dont une petite troupe avec un
copain qui a plongé parce que faute de
financement et puis l'arrivée à paris et
violente paris est une ville magnifique
mais pas forcément hospitalière pour
quelqu'un qui a pas un sou en poche bref
des petits boulots à l'époque on pouvait
trouver du boulot facilement et puis
le hasard toujours
une cet élève dont vous ai parlé
par sont donc m'indiquer le court
périmony qui était à l'époque un des
cours avec le coach jean laurent cochet
un des courses solides
respecté du métier auditions je suis
plein troisième année au théâtre de
l'athénée louis jouvet ou périmony
exercés à l'époque
repéré par un journaliste qui était venu
aux auditions première pièce ou café
théâtre la véritable histoire de paul et
virginie où je fais paul au côté sophie
chauveau qui sortait du conservatoire et
puis un agent marcenais le noir qui m'a
permis de faire mes premiers films à
l'écran et puis après bombay les choses
s'enchaînent quand on fait bien son
travail qu'on est sérieux bain
le hasard aide à trouver du boulot
le dîner de cons justement vous en
parliez tout à l'heure le dîner de cons
c'est peut-être le moment phare de votre
carrière à votre avis où pas vraiment
phare je sais pas inattendu totalement
c'est le seul rôle pour lequel j'ai pas
passer d'audition pourquoi parce que
j'avais et contribuer à montage d'un
film qui était co produit par canal et
tf1 qui s'appelle car audace
j'avais le rôle principal est le
deuxième rôle principal avait été
attribuée à pierre mondy qui à l'époque
faisait des cordiers où j'avais fait
deux épisodes avec pierre on s'entend
très bien on passe un mois et demi
ensemble pour tourner on se voit plus
deux ans après un coup de fil un matin
c'est pierre on est en juillet il me dit
tu es libre en janvier prochain bruit il
me dit bon écoute si tu veux tu peux tu
peux reprendre le rôle de lucien cheval
dans le dîner de cons francis veber est
ok parce qu'il ne connaissait pas ce que
j'avais fait sept films avec jacques
otmezguine qui est un ami à francis
veber si c'est oui tu me dis que j
attends j'ai pas vu la pièce dont tu as
deux places qui t'attend j'y vais
évidemment la pièce est magnifique
j'accepte et lui jours après je signe
pour trois tournées et les zénith qui
s'enchaînent et ce rôle ils vous voient
parfaitement
c'est un rôle magnifique est daniel
prévost a été été excellent au cinéma et
il a eu un césar très méritée ce rôle
m'a permet de jouer entre ce que je
qualifierais avec beaucoup d'amour d'une
formule 1 qui était jacques villeret et
d'une bentley qui était michel roux qui
était comme ça c'était cadré comme un
coup sous suis j'étais entre les deux et
j'ai beaucoup appris et je me suis
beaucoup amusé merci à eux 2 à francis
veber et à pire monde il avait également
écrit à des pièces notamment pétanque et
sentiments on va justement regardez un
extrait siens ben écoute tout d'abord je
vais réattaquer le sport
à fond les boules je vais essayer de
jouer à la pétanque au moins une fois
par semaine
et bien la vinothérapie comment vous
dire ces nouveaux traitements anti
stress à base de résine il paraît que ça
marche pour le même bien mais là où lui
il est très très fort ces kits est
personnellement tous ces produits
une pièce que vous avez joué plus de 300
fois je crois en tournée aux tournées en
tournée j'ai créé à paris au théâtre
michel ensuite la centième a eu lieu au
théâtre de la huchette à paris
qui avait eu à l'époque un molière
d'honneur pour la qualité sa
programmation et puis elle est partie en
tournée 4 festival d'avignon deux mois
molière de versailles et plus de 300
tournée web qu'est ce qui fait la force
de pétanque et sentiments votre avis
d'abord c'est une comédie et d'une
ensuite qui colportent de l'amour
beaucoup d'amour et qui sous un côté
léger permet à celles et ceux qui
veut les voir un peu plus profondément
des messages qui nous concerne tous ça
c'est un peu votre histoire nous a mis
dedans ce spectacle pétanque et
sentiments ou pas vraiment oui et non
c'est pas une bonne réponse mais dans
tous mes spectacles
dont le 8e là que je vais jouer en
avignon oui il ya toujours un peu de moi
je l'écris avec l'antre de mon sens
parce que c'est ce que je connais le
mieux parce que j'ai la chance d'avoir
une vie un peu atypique le jeune
marginal de d'avoir pu naviguer
zigzaguer un peu partout donc je profite
de ce que j'ai vu de ce que j'ai vécu
pour essayer de le transmettre et de le
transmettre un message utile pour les
uns les unes et les autres et ça parle
de quoi justement pétanque et sentiments
de la vie répétant que sentiment c'est
ça se passe dans un village perdu qui
fait un peu écho à rennes-le-château
comprenne qui pourra un mystère il ya un
un curé qui est pauvre mais qui refait
complètement l'église avec de l'argent
qui vient d'on ne sait où il ya cet
homme le patron qui n'a pas de nom il
vient de loin d'ailleurs on comprend
qu'il a une histoire
un peu marginal il passe ici par hasard
peut-être pour se planquer il rencontre
une femme coup de foudre il a un enfant
elle meurt mais pour elle lui a racheté
le café de la vie qui était qui était le
seul bistrot du village et
il avait offert il reste là il est bien
là et là bas c'est un point de concours
entre les personnages du village et
d'autre de la ville comme un commissaire
de police comme il ya le maire il ya un
député qui clôt hasardeux de communion
liquide qui se passe au comptoir
permettent
d'éclairer peut-être certains mystères
de l'existence
j'espère avoir été clair
et petite précision pour les
téléspectateurs vous êtes seul sur scène
ouais je suis seul en scène pourquoi
d'abord c'est un seul en scène c'est pas
un one man show c'est pas un stand up et
tout le respect que je porte à ces
pratiques ensuite c'est une comédie en
trois actes tout mais seul en scène sont
des comédie en trois actes avec un seul
personnage qui ont entouré d'autres
personnages qui passent et auquel qui
existent qu'on voit la presse en
témoigne allez voir
des quatre coins de france on est
confiant qu'on voit les personnages qui
existent par la magie du verbe et le jeu
de l'acteur alors pourquoi tout seul
parce qu'après le dîner de cons sans
prétention je j'osais espérer avoir
d'autres jolis rôles comme ça et puis
comme ça arrive dans beaucoup de
parcours jeudi par contre j'aime pas le
mot carrière donc
bois vague des choses plus ou moins
intéressantes donc je me suis dit bat
pour sortir de cette impasse écrite et
spectacle écrit ce que tu as envie de
jouer construit les comédies que tu as
envie d'interpréter et là j'en suis à ma
huitième ça vous plaît à décrire ah
ouais oui d'abord parce qu'on c'est un
challenge on parle d'une page blanche on
a un stylo lors il y avait avec l'ombre
de son sens je le répète parce qu'on
peut pas si on si on injecte pas son
énergie son vécu son ressenti sa
relation au kosovo théorique on peut pas
me semble-t-il ont enfin moi en tout cas
je peux pas faire des choses
intéressantes si je si je n'ai pas tout
ça vous écrivait régulièrement du coup
toutes les semaines oui papa papa c'est
souvent parce que gégé vous raconter ma
vie les différentes activités en
parallèle j'ai dans le cas de mon métier
je fais différentes choses on peut
vérifier cela aussi sur google met donc
je procrastine un petit peu au désespoir
de mon éditeur parce que j'ai trois
lignes qui sont en attente sur
l'alchimie du verbe un second sur le
festival d'avignon est il une vengeance
templière et le troisième sur le quai le
texte de mon nouveau spectacle qui
s'appelle apocalypse républicaine mais
justement ça fera partie de vos grands
projets pour les pour les prochaines
années est ce que vous pouvez nous en
dire un peu plus sur apocalypse
républicaine oui bien sûr il y aura une
lecture qui va se faire au festival
d'avignon le 9 juillet au théâtre pierre
de lune dans le cadre de hauteur en
liberté ou vont passer eric emmanuel
schmitt dire note des beaucoup d'autres
et moi même pire note en étant le
parrain de cette manifestation
ensuite une grande nouvelle pour les
yvelines lecture aura lieu au théâtre de
ben ali le 19 septembre c'est un
vendredi il reste encore beaucoup de
place ne vous retenez pas réservés
lecture c'est à dire qu'est ce qu'est ce
que vous allez faire pour pourquoi des
lectures ça se pratique beaucoup
maintenant il ya quelques temps encore
c'était un peu mystérieux et puis randy
et evi ragnetti on a fait plusieurs os à
versailles au théâtre montansier une
lecture dont l'on lui le texte de cette
pièce en règle générale enfin en ce qui
me concerne je c'est la première fois
que je fais ça mais je lis de textes
d'une pièce qui n'a pas affronté
l'épreuve du public qui n'a pas affronté
l'acte d'amour entre le verbe l'acteur
et le public ça permet de polir en plus
apocalypse républicaine ou doutez bien
que
c'est pas du ronsard c'est pas mignonne
allons voir si la rose bon voilà cela
dit je n'attaque personne je n'agresse
personne je mets juste un coup
d'éclairage et des ressentis et des
commentaires sur des choses qui nous
qui nous concerne tous qui nous rendent
tous tristes et et devant lesquels on
est parfois impuissants mais face auquel
il faut garder beaucoup d'espoir et ne
jamais commettre le péché de
désespérance et vous allez également
tourné dans quelques films dans les
prochains mois oui j'ai plusieurs films
à faire dans celui de pétanque et
sentiments qui se monte qui a donné
naissance et un scénario devient un film
we alors là tous les personnages qui
existent sur scène existants et qui
seront ou une personnalité ont une
histoire en caractères gras
c'est encore montage j'ai une
coproduction suis sûr on avoir une belge
et là je suis je cherche une production
française si un producteur qui écoute
voilà j'en avais eu dans le pire du f2p
vide et puis j'ai deux autres films
aussi un 2-2 gauthier bar à vins jeunes
cinéastes qu'habite versailles qui
s'appelle le monstre dans la vallée dans
lequel j'ai j'ai un des rôles principaux
et plus enfin différentes choses mais
faut pas trop parler de choses qui sont
pas encore fait la retraite attendra
pour vous bernard bat pour pour un pour
un artiste quel qu'il soit la bouche et
les soixante dix ans et sa part d'ombré
approcher les 70 ans âge me d'étape à la
fin de l'année
mais me font pas peur
et puis bon dans mon métier tant qu'on a
la chance d'avoir la santé l'énergie et
puis le la niaque on peut continuer
autant que faire se peut michel galabru
nous l'a prouvé et il est parti à 93 ans
il jouait encore magnifiquement quelques
quelques mois avant quelques semaines
avant merci beaucoup mais raffinée ça
sera le mot de la fin merci à vous et à
bientôt pour un nouveau numéro de v y
pêcher
[Musique]
je